foreign
[Music]
this is the role that shot Olivia
Newton-John to International stardom
starring opposite John Travolta as Sandy
in Greece
the 1978 film became the biggest
grossing musical of the 20th century and
was the Pinnacle of the british-born
Australian singer's career which had
already seen her sell more than 100
million records I've never seen this
before but this is a collection of I say
most of my gold and platinum records
over the years
Newton John went on to win four Grammys
after Greece including one for her work
on this
accredited for starting this
questionable fashion trend forever tied
to the 80s
Newton John's work stretched beyond
music and the Silver Screen she served
as Goodwill Ambassador for the United
Nations before being diagnosed with
breast cancer in 1992.
she turned her 30-year battle with the
disease into advocacy and philanthropy
founding the Olivia Newton-John cancer
and Wellness Center in Melbourne
Australia
in 2020 she was recognized by the UK's
Queen Elizabeth who appointed her a Dame
what's the one memory that stands out
the most from 40 years ago meeting
Olivia throughout it all she remained
close with her Greece co-star John
Travolta from 40 years earlier
[Music]
yes I think we had crushes on each other
but we both were seeing other people and
but I think that's what made the
chemistry work
after her passing Travolta writing on
Instagram my dearest Olivia yours from
the first moment I saw you and forever
you're Danny you're John
[Music]
Olivia Newton-John was 73. Leah Harding
Al Jazeera